-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching.
Let's get to some news.
Today President Biden gave
his first commencement address
as commander in chief at the
Coast Guard Academy graduation.
Yeah, Biden's speech
lasted about 30 minutes
until a Coast Guard captain
fired off a rescue flare.
It's like, "Wrap it up, buddy."
[ Laughter ]
Even Navy S.E.A.L.s were looking
at the Coast Guard like,
"How did you make it
through that?"
[ Laughter ]
But this was nice. Biden
personally handed out diplomas
to all 240 graduates.
Then Fox News criticized him for
more government handouts.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You could tell Biden is 78
'cause he also gave
every graduate a check for $10.
[ Laughter ]
"Don't spend it all
in one place."
At the end of his visit,
Biden received a gift.
It was pretty special.
Take a look at this.
-On behalf of the class of 2021,
I would like to present to you
this token of our appreciation.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good joke.
He said the same thing
at Christmas
when his grandkids got him
a Life Alert.
[ Laughter ]
On his ride home, he used the
sword to open a string cheese.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, that'll explain why
he shows up to his next event
wearing an eye patch.
You what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Got a sword.
What is he gonna do with this?
Popping bottles of Ensure.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Side note, by the way --
why does the Coast Guard
carry swords?
[ Laughter ]
Shouldn't it be
a harpoon or something?
[ Laughter ]
Guarding the coast like,
"Something's coming down
the coast!
Let's wait till they land
and get about two feet from us,
then we can defend ourselves."
Get them bazookas.
What are we doing?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Biden spent the day
with the Coast Guard's
newest graduates,
which brings us
to a new segment called
"Inspiring words
from your commander in chief."
♪♪
-You're a really dull class.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, this is interesting.
I saw that kids ages 13 to 17
can officially trade stocks
with Fidelity's
new youth investing accounts.
Yeah, you'll know your kids
are too into trading
when they're up at 3:00 a.m.
for the Asian markets,
downing Pixy Stix.
[ Laughter ]
I can already see a dad
threatening to cut off
his son's allowance
and the son just smiles
and lights a cigar with a 50.
[ Laughter ]
"Why don't you go mow the lawn,
Dad?"
[ Laughter ]
Get this. Google just announced
a new privacy feature
that will allow users to delete
the last 15 minutes
of their search history.
It's easy. You just go to
Settings and turn on Perv Mode.
[ Laughter ]
That's very simple.
Some more business news --
Dunkin' Donuts just announced
a new partnership
with a paint company
for the chain's first ever
paint collection.
[ Laughter ]
It's for anyone who's ever
walked into a Dunkin' Donuts
like, "I want to live here."
[ Laughter ]
I saw that next month
General Mills is releasing
four of its most popular cereals
in oatmeal form.
Or you could just pour milk
into your favorite cereal
and wait literally 10 seconds.
[ Laughter ]
It's Wheaties.
It's spackle.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Lucky Charms oatmeal.
And if you're looking for
a healthier breakfast option,
I recommend drinking
Dunkin' Donuts paint.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not a doctor.
Finally, I read about
an Air France flight
that travelled nearly seven
hours from Paris to Montreal
powered by used cooking oil.
Yeah, it's great if you don't
mind spending seven hours
knowing that you're on a plane
powered by used cooking oil.
It's like, "Only 6 hours
and 49 minutes left, everybody.
We're almost -- We can do this.
We can do this."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, the cooking-oil flight
landed on time,
but they had to wait 10 minutes
under a heat lamp
until someone came
and picked them up.
Did you see that President Biden
actually test-drove the elec--
-Yes.
-It was in Michigan yesterday.
But they gave him a full tour of
the whole thing, and anyways,
he had some things to teach them
as well, apparently.
-Really?
-Well, they asked him
what he thought of
the whole truck.
Here's what he had to say.
[ Laughter and applause ]
What?
-Really?
That's what he said to them?
-I don't know.
Later in his tour
of the plant --
he was looking at
the whole plant in Michigan,
and he said this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow, what's he talking about?
-He's at the plant.
Might as well talk about
the truck or something.
Then he left them with this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Really?
-I don't know, man.
They got him out of there.